il ya un magnet chapalain qui est avec
nous ce qu'on allait vraiment dans le
sujet est une française rapatriés de
human de paix mise en quarantaine à
carry le rouet j'étais à côté de jean
pierre foucault
voilà il aurait pu vous faire gagner des
millions non c'est vrai alors vous êtes
étudiante en master vous vivez à vannes
depuis quatre ans et demi et vous
souhaitez y retourner très vite alors
vous dites vous avez reçu l' alerte le
23 janvier comment ça s'est passé
alors début janvier on a entendu parler
de quelques cas de pneumonie oui mais
c'était pas alertant ensuite c'est
vraiment mi-janvier qu'on a entendu
parler d'un virus et le 22e on savait
toujours pas ce qui se passait le 23 au
matin on nous dit la ville est fermée on
peut plus partir donc c'est là que la
panique et est arrivé les gens sont rués
dans les supermarchés pour faire des
provisions
tout le monde à porter un masque dès le
23 et puis va on est restés enfermés
chez nous alors vous avez fait des
provisions ou à essayer de quitter la
ville en prenant de train d'être un ou
des bus mais impossible impossible donc
la ville et c'est quoi c'est une ville
fantôme ouais personnes dans les rues
personnes vous êtes vous n'aviez pas le
droit de sortir on avait le droit de
sortir d'accord quand j'ai été on avait
encore le droit de sortir mais ça
n'avait plus d'intérêt parce que tout
était fermé
d'accord alors vous héritez au consulat
français vous a proposé le rapatriement
oui alors vous les bus vouliez vous
vouliez pas rentrer non et en fait c'est
votre maman qui vous a pas laissé le
choix je vous ai dit tu rends maintenant
ouais infamie ils m'ont laissé le choix
mais il était inquiet donc j'ai préféré
rentrer d'accord alors vous avez passé
deux semaines en quarantaine a eu and
plus deux semaines
à carry-le-rouet en quarantaine alors
comment ça s'est passé
c'est long c'est long ah ouais c'est
pourquoi alors vous étiez quoi dans une
vous étiez ou en quarantaine j'étais à
carry le rouet d'accord où ça dans un
autre ensemble de vacances d'accord on
n'était pas enfermé dans le champ
mauvais sortir danser quand vous étiez
tout une vous étiez combien on était
deux cent trente et un d'accord j'aurais
quand même passé une petit centre de
vacances quoi de semaine au club mais la
cua tranquille quoi la base de haut 10
heures tir à l'arc 11h aquagym quoi dans
le steak ou alors le programme
franchement non on faisait rien
riendeau journée bon même pas de cours
de biologie un merci yann et y avait
tous les âges aussi d'en mesurer way et
à y avait des familles incroyable de
vivre sa mine de rien vous avez passé
deux semaines mais c'est vrai c'est une
expérience mais non si vous nous suivez
soit en direct dans balances ton post
c'est quand même une vraie une
expérience incroyable c'est vrai qu'on
se dit ça c'est unique vous allez vous
en souvenir toute votre vie tsé-tsé deux
semaines vraiment où vous avez fait des
connaissances avec des gens vous avez
fait vous êtes fait des amis dans la
whey j'avais gardé contact avec des gens
avec qui vous étiez en quarantaine
pendant pendant deux semaines et on se
dit quoi alors on est on est inquiet on
se dit quoi on dit on se dit qu'il se
passe peut-être un flacon et qu'on est
au centre d'un truc d'un phénomène
incroyable
ouais quand même on était soulagé d'être
en très inquiet parce que moi je compte
y retourner j'ai des amis qui sont
encore haouran mais vrai que c'est
inquiétant quand on est rentré en france
on était on était soulagés personnes
étaient infectées donc ouais et vouziers
contrôler ouais quand ça s'est passé les
contrôles c'est ça ouais on prenait
notre température deux fois par jour
ouais d'accord puis il ya un médecin qui
passaient tous les matins dans la
chambre et il y avait des gens qui
étaient contaminées dont les gt dans le
deuxième vol est effectivement il y
avait un cas d'accord était confirmée un
allèle jal ya un cas qui étaient
confirmés d'accord qui est avec vous à
carry le rouet maintenant il est rentré
directement un belge est d'accord donc
lui direct ils ont ils ont fait rentrer
en belgique et donc dans les 240
personnes qui étaient avec moi carry le
rouet aucune personne ne présentait le
corps navires us aux rachats d'accord à
42 rassurant de se dire que malgré un
différend s acquitter au foyer dans le
centre même de wuhan où il y avait le
plus d'épidémie rationnellement ouvrir
l'amp sûrs et aucun but c'est un atout
français n'a été contaminé donc c'est
peut-être un message un peu positif
bien sûr c'est un message plutôt
positive